Peter Brown here at the game spot news  update today it was announced that just  cause 3 is in development the latest  game informer cover reveals art for the  game and that it will be coming to  playstation 4 xbox one and pc Just Cause  3 is expected to release in 2015 the  previous game in the series just cause 2  came out in 2010 Game Informer editors  played the game for several hours and  report that as parachute and grapple  mechanics have been improved there was  also a brand new wing suit the game will  be set in a fictional Mediterranean  archipelago Just Cause 3 is in  development by Avalanche at their New  York City office 2015 will be a big year  for avalanche as the developer also  plans to launch Mad Max for consoles and  PC next year we'll have more news on  Just Cause 3 over at gamespot com / news  as it becomes available